كان لدي العديد من مدربي الطيران
والمساهمين في تدريبي لمعرفة
ذلك لمعرفة كيف يمكنك التخطيط
للطائرة بقدميك نحن في
حالة جيدة لقد حصلت على اعتماد من قبل إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) للطيران
في عام 2008 استعدادًا للطيران هناك
هو الشيء الحاسم  أن أكون قادرًا على
الوصول إلى النير بقدمي اليمنى أيضًا
مع قدمي اليسرى وبالتالي
التحكم في دواسة الوقود ومن ثم أيضًا
أن أكون قادرًا على الوصول إلى أدوات التحكم اللاسلكية التي
ولدت بدون ذراعي حتى
يومنا هذا ، ولا يعرف الأطباء
سبب ذلك  في سن الخامسة ،
تعرفت على ذراعي اصطناعيين ، لذا
لم أحب الأطراف الاصطناعية
منذ البداية لأنني كنت أستطيع القيام
بالأشياء بشكل أفضل وأكثر كفاءة
بقدمي ، كنت أرغب كثيرًا في أن أكون طبيعية
وقد قيل لي في
كثير من الأحيان أن  لم أستطع فعل شيء ما
أو أنني كنت معاقًا ، وقد
استاءت تمامًا من كلمة إعاقة
بخلاف كوني طيارًا
أنا غواص سكوبا معتمد لقد تعلمت كيفية ركوب الأمواج
أنا راكب دراجة أحب السباحة ، شكرًا أنا
الزواج  لقد التقينا من خلال التايكوندو ،
أنا الحزام الأسود من الدرجة الثالثة في
التايكوندو عندما أتسلق السلالم
أستخدم ذقني في كتفي ، سافرت
كمتحدث الآن إلى 23 دولة كان
لدي قدوة وقادة ولأنني
كان ذلك الآن مسؤوليتي أن
أكون هو نفسه بالنسبة للجيل القادم